I'm Jaleh Sadravi and I'm an alumna of Valparaiso University.
I think that Martin Luther King Jr. Day is a great time to reflect and remember the legacy of a man...
...that taught this country about peace and justice.
If you want to be great, wonderful!
But recognize that he who is greatest among you shall be your servant.
My favorite speech of Dr. King is "The Beloved Community."
In this speech, he encourages everyone to come together no matter their race or their creed.
While I was a student at Valpo, I enjoyed the events that honored his legacy.
Valpo had four weeks of celebration,...
...offering the campus community a chance to embrace diversity...
...and to learn more about social justice issues.
Every year, MLK Day is highlighted by a convocation.
There is a keynote speaker who inspires the campus with their own story.
There are also awards given to those on campus that encourage diversity.
Lively music is sung and I would encourage everyone to attend,...
...for this is truly an enjoyable experience.
So come be a part of our celebration here at Valpo,...
...and see for yourself what MLK Day is all about.